pas le capitole paisible symbole du
congrès mais dans ses murs c'est la
tonitruante division des américains
c'est une guerre d'image et de mots que
se livrent républicains et démocrates
pour convaincre les américains du bien
fondé ou pas de la possible destitution
de donald trump
la leader démocrate brandi le drapeau
pour lequel tant d'américains se sont
battus dans l'autre camp on dénonce 37
jours de procédure à la soviétique avec
des témoignages
loin des caméras de m6 sans surprise les
républicains ont voté contre cette
nouvelle étape dans la procédure de
destitution
ce sont les démocrates majoritaires à la
chambre qui ont eu le dernier mot
à partir de maintenant la plupart des
témoins seront entendus non plus à huis
clos mais bien en audience publique
c'est donc l'occasion pour les
démocrates de démontrer ce qu'ils
appellent un abus du pouvoir
présidentiel de donald trump à des fins
personnelles au centre de cette enquête
une conversation téléphonique entre le
président américain et son homologue
ukrainien retenait une aide militaire de
près de 400 millions de dollars votés
par le congrès pour venir en aide aux
ukrainiens dans leur guerre contre la
russie en échange de ce coup de main
financier le président trump demandait
une petite faveur que l'ukraine enquête
sur le fils de joe biden l'un des
prétendants à la maison blanche par
baden a oeuvré au sein d'une compagnie
minière ukrainienne alors qu'il y
flottait un parfum de corruption
mais jusqu'à ce jour aucune preuve d'une
quelconque implication de by john
larroquette de donald trump a beau être
partisane et déplacé pour un président
qui dans ce cas ci a demandé un chef
d'état étranger d'interférer dans une
campagne à la maison blanche
celui-ci ne voilà que la plus grande
chasse aux sorcières de l'histoire
américaine et la maison blanche
d'ajouter les démocrates veulent rendre
un verdict sans donner à
l'administration une chance de se
défendre
une déclaration erronée puisque avec
cette nouvelle étape de la procédure de
destitution
les républicains peuvent non seulement
contre interroger les éventuels témoins
à charge du président mais aussi
proposer leurs propres témoins encore
faut-il que les républicains collaborent
à cette enquête
or jusqu'ici selon les démocrates le
contrôle n'a fait que mettre des bâtons
dans les roues de la procédure et le
rejet massif des républicains
aujourd'hui ne laisse présager aucune
collaboration ici frédéric arnould
radio-canada washington